all right little mama and master jay
hello
welcome back
how you doing thank you it's good to see
you guys again tell me what's been going
on in your world
oh well
wor world's been like a war it's been
really quite like
crazy um
[Music]
which
it's hard for us because we're trying to
get off into doing some different things
we don't want to be in the game no more
like we want to we want to do something
i know me like i've been like applying
for jobs has gotten hard to make money
on the streets
yeah it's getting harder
jay can you help with that
excuse me can you help with the finances
at all
i'm quite sure i i've been doing little
odd jobs
here and there and it just ain't working
out i mean
come on now i'm a manager
and you know even even
those
even that's getting hard put it that way
mark this culvert stuff sucks
it's good but it sucks
you know you guys have been together how
long
too long
too long we've been together like three
to four years now
how much your time is spent fighting
um
22 hours of the day
maybe a year or two
22 hours at a year
at the end of it i keep asking him why
that's why
that's why we fight because like it's
ridiculous i know i stay with him
because i really care for him i really
love him i don't know what
what he sees me as i don't know maybe
i'm his
at the end of the day he can just like
land on me and i'll drop in the ground
and he'll be set
maybe you guys deserve each other who
knows
what's in the bag
um
first some personal things like lotion
and
personal if you tell him
well he acts
like lotion and stuff like that
just making sure there's no gun in there
no no way
no babe
and where do you guys stay now
well we're still moving around we're
still moving around
um
i don't know
we're we're not together as much as we
used to be but i'm hoping that that'll
change
you know um what do you what would you
like to see
jay do or how would you like to see him
change
how i would like to see him change is
this instead of him getting mad at me
and wanting to fight me all the time
maybe he should try to grab me and and
hold me
that's what i would like to see
more loving and less fighting
even if i'm mad you know
because i know if somebody's really mad
at me that's what i try to do
that's what i would try to do
jay what would you like to
see little mama do or change
uh
just get herself together make her mind
up
where she's gonna go which i mean
come on god put us one thing about it
god will put somebody in your life
he has a reason but we don't want to
decide
we don't want to make the idea oh that
person's going to stay in my life
forever
that might be not being god's plan
right now
what i've learned since the last time we
talked
is to try to focus more on what god
wants
because this is
people change
on you
in the middle of the road
i i'm not used to that
i don't like that
i'm not a fighter
as you know per se as you know people
may
you know be led to think
but i ain't go back down neither
kid woman child man whatever
you know
i'm a leo if i'm challenged
i'm gonna come out
you guys have good times together
there's still some yes
there's still some parts of the
relationship there yes we get we get our
laughs in and stuff like that but i
think the pressure of the world and the
pressure of
some of our peers
he's getting to somebody here's the
thing i'm gonna tell you what's going on
you know we're already going through
like a lot of jealousy problems
and stuff like that right
and
and then it's like
you know it's it's
sad to say but it's an envious thing
it's an envious thing it's like
you know well i thought you had a life
like dude what do i need to tell you to
get a life or something
like why are you guys all up in our
business now
24 7. you know you guys were doing your
own thing and when we were there you
guys were showing us off and now we're
together the moment we get together and
hang out here you guys come
want to want to
do you guys have people in your lives
that you you trust
we try but it never works it never works
out you trust each other
yeah
we do
we do and then it is
uh it's hurtful because sometimes trust
gets broken
but at the end of the day we know where
we're coming from
you know what i mean we know that we
feel like you're on the same team yeah
that's good
so and drugs are still a part of your
life
not like they used to be huh
no
yeah
i don't know mark i want wanna
i was telling him like i wanna do some
different things i wanna i wanna take a
cruise or something i wanna go to hawaii
i wanna do some different things with
him you know
and and just but
i don't know what i don't i don't know
if this man has another life with others
i don't know what's going on
because it's not going through it's not
happening and me i have a family too
i have i have others in my life too
but i'm trying to show him that i can
make time for him
and i don't know what's going on with
him but i just
since i have seen you mark i think i
lost my sister and my mother yeah and i
just got word
i just got word today that
my other sister out here looking for me
because it supposed to be another death
in the family and i'm scared to call
i don't i don't want to hear it
but i know
i i'm gonna have to
um
and i have to be there for him when that
comes up
because at the end of the day i'm ready
i am you know like just ready to just
separate myself like
where where our camper is and stuff
you know i had found a sofa i found a
piece of carpet i found some mattresses
and i was about to set my own thing up
you know what i mean and then he comes
at me like this and it just like i just
everything just dropped you know
and and then it's like when you're in
situations like that you still have to
go through
other
you know
situations you know
it's hard out there
it is it is
you get depressed you get angry with
what happens when emotions come up most
often
you know what i i know this
i know by you
letting us you know do this interview
it's going to help a lot because at the
end of the day i don't care what i've
been talking about i don't care what's
going on i don't care what happens when
we go back out there and i'm talking
about how he's doing this with somebody
and how i'm doing that with somebody
we go stick together and we go we we
we're about to go well we go get her you
want to get a room and take a shower and
just
get out the world
so yeah now i got to shut up because i'm
talking about things that we need
that need that's gonna help us feel
better and he wants me to be quiet i
think i'm gonna try to work on being
quiet
are you guys faithful to each other 100
look he knows what i do right
you know he knows that i'm faithful to
him
now ask him is he faithful to me
don't
yeah we are
we are
i'll answer that
because what little mama's doing for
money is just what she's doing for money
is that's not really that's it and i
keep telling him that over and over
again i don't care about
you know what i mean i
i care what it is is
maybe that's the problem
you know what i mean that i really i
i'm really not even i'm trying to do
what i got to do so i can
maybe a miracle that happened or
something i don't know mark i don't know
it's a complicated relationship isn't it
yeah but
before we we um
[Music]
i don't know before we separate we go
you know we're not gonna go out
backwards i'm sorry i'm not gonna
separate from him like this
and he's not gonna separate from me like
this
i'm sorry
i don't care how hard i got a fight
[Music]
what's funny
who are you laughing at me or you
or every a lot of you just whatever you
think i'm joking i don't know or maybe
he's joking
you want to take off the glasses maybe
you might see your face
take your hat off oh yeah handsome man
he's got good eyes beautiful eyes
that's my froggy
what's your favorite thing about little
mama
okay
i smile
i smile
it's just i gotta take and then like he
i'm we're gonna go to the hospital too
because he's having oh my god he had a
okay baby
we'll be done in a second
see
see when you hate yapping people when
you do that you know what i'm saying
sometimes just have to
well that's we're here to talk
we're doing an interview boy we can't
just sit here
yes we can can't anymore mark i am i do
am i doing what we're supposed to do
you're doing a great job
i'm trying yeah we're here to talk
it's true i'm not here to just sit here
stare at the camera
what's your favorite thing about
jay
this right here
that's being able to
pull
through
you guys you guys figure out a way to
get through
yeah
always do
oh i do
would like to be in five years
in five years mark i want to be doing
something different i want to be [ __ ]
managing the mcdonald's
and having like my own spot and don't
have to be in the streets and
i want you know i want him to
you know i i don't want i want i don't
want him to i want him to work but i
don't want him to do
a bunch of hard work or work hard
a little bit i want us to be a team i
want to i want to enjoy some dinners
with him
matter of fact if if we could get our
crazy
uh
cousin out there that just did the
interview
curly
if we could get her to take us to this i
already got to set up what i want us to
have for lunch today and everything and
nobody take me nowhere okay well
whatever i i i know what i'm gonna go
get i know what i'm having for lunch
today
mark you got to try it the best
chinese food place
it's off of 130 in wilmington i don't
know if you've been that's like by the
nickerson project area
they have these egg rolls they make they
like the size of burritos
and they have like shrimp real shrimp
and
uh beef and steak and chicken in them
but what i like is the rice the fried
rice
that you get from a chinese it's more
like home-cooked rice
and it's so good simple simple pleasures
yeah
so i just want us to
so jay take a little mama for some
chinese food
i i'll be taking him you'll be taking
him but that's okay because we're gonna
take care of each other
there you go
all right you guys great seeing you
again
thank you thank you
you guys are you guys are survivors
thank you
thank you thank you america
stay tuned and i'm gonna tell
i'm gonna tell you guys
you guys better stop bothering mark
because one day y'all go come see him
and me or frog is gonna pop up at this
door
thank you
you